- [Voiceover] "Which of
the following is equivalent
"to the above expression?"
So, they have p plus
one, squared, minus four.
Then I have all of these choices,
p plus one plus two, times
p plus one minus two,
p minus one plus two, time
p minus one minus two.
And so these kind of are reminiscent
of difference of squares.
And when you look at this right over here,
this is indeed a difference of squares.
We could rewrite this one as,
this is the same thing
as p plus one, squared,
minus two squared.
This literally is a difference of squares.
And you might remember from your algebra,
if I have a squared minus b squared,
this can be factored out as a plus b,
times a minus b.
So we can do the same thing over here.
This thing is going to be,
and we're not used to treating
an expression like p plus one
as our a, but there's
no reason why we can't.
This is going to be equal to,
and let me color-code it.
This is going to be the
product of two things.
It's going to be the
So, it's going to be p plus one...
so, p plus one here, p plus one here.
And then, plus b and minus b.
In this case, b is two.
So, plus two and then minus two.
Once again, this is just
a difference of squares.
And I encourage you to search
for difference of squares on Khan Academy
if this is looking
completely foreign to you.
Well, this is kind of an
interesting variation on it.
This is actually fully described
by this one right over here.
Do that in the appropriate color.
All right, p plus one plus two,
times p plus one minus two.
Yep, that one right there.